tokyo game show is such a spectacle of
lights of colors of sound everything's
vying for your attention it's honestly
sometimes overwhelming but I knew what I
wanted to do this year I'm a good buddy
Alexa help me out we went right to the
sony booth and I played gravity rush too
if you play gravity rush you would
absolutely love this it's everything you
liked about the original game but it's
more beautiful it's the same style right
so it's like comic esque style and
you're still the same character your cat
but the world is just elevated
everything is much higher you can fly to
higher heights combat is changed now
they've mixed it up a little bit and
giving you way more options I think it's
gonna be such a great game and I was
really looking forward to it I've got a
very short 10 minute demo but in my
three days of Tokyo that's what I'm
going to remember the most flying high
and gravity rush to it was my highlight
I come to Japan for one thing and one
thing only and that is persona 5 I
played it on the show for tokyo game
show and i cannot stop thinking about it
it was about a 15 minute demo where
you're about eight hours into the main
game and you have the protagonist and
his two best friends you'll have more
goner yet which kind of sucks but it
gives a really good sense of how the
dungeons and how combat has changed from
all the other persona series it's boy
it's colourful that game could win game
of the year on its UI and graphics alone
and the dream isn't even over it came
out in japan on thursday so i bought a
copy and I'm taking it home with me and
that my favorite thing in tokyo game
show this is my first tgs and my first
video game convention ever and i've got
to say it has blown my mind but my
favorite thing i did with my time here
in Tokyo was when i went to the Bandai
Namco project I can be our arcade it was
crazy I'm so new to VR that every
experience was just mind-blowing for me
the worst and best thing I did was it
was this VR game where I went up in an
elevator and had to rescue a cat on a
plank you're watching the video now you
can see me shaking and the worst part of
that whole trip is mary was shooting me
and halfway through she just SAT very
quietly to herself this is the saddest
thing I've ever seen and that's what I
will remember for the rest of my days
and that was the best thing that
happened to me in Tokyo this year
thanks you guys for hanging out and
watching all about stuff and for
everything gaming make sure you keep it
at gamespot
you